they love hearing that [ __ ] and they
don't want to hear anything differently
do you know what's going on right now
but unity Yeti coolers and the NRA no
it's fascinating because this just shows
how tribal and crazy people get Yeti
coolers they cancelled some they had
these programs like go to go to do you
know my friend Ben O'Brien's Instagram
do you know that yeah put it on Adam
green trees and we could read it but
what what Yeti did they discontinued
these I forget what they the way they
describe the program but they had a
bunch of outdated incentive programs
where like you know like if you signed
up for something get a discount like if
this kind of program here it is
discounted discounting program Yeti
makes super high-end coolers okay
they look really expensive but they
literally will keep ice for days you
could put ice in them and go to the
desert and five days later you have ice
in that cooler and I'm not [ __ ] like
they're [ __ ] phenomenal this exact
way to do it nice they're phenomenal so
anyway they notified the NRA and the
organization's has changed Yeti
explained to them that they're offering
an alternative customization program
broadly available to consumers and
organizations including the NRA
Foundation so then the NRA releases this
statement that Yeti coolers doesn't want
to work with the NRA anymore they don't
support the Second Amendment so [ __ ]
them so people start blowing up their
Yeti coolers up with that thermite [ __ ]
or what is that stuff not thermite
what's that explosion patek had a bunch
of that [ __ ] in his car what is that
[ __ ] not whatever they is that what it
is and Yeti supporters blown up Yeti
coolers you can suck my dick
I'm American so they filled it up with
this explosive [ __ ] and by the way these
coolers are [ __ ] expensive they're
super engineered and you know they start
at like 300 bucks so this is
below this thing I'm telling you these
people are just looking for an excuse to
blow [ __ ] up but there's a great quote
in this article which is this article
from what is this website does the
Washington Post nuts there's there's a
great quote in this article that sort of
highlights how [ __ ] preposterous this
all is it's people are such babies
so it's good god but I don't think it's
that what I really think is that they
want an enemy they're happy when
something happens and even though yetis
explained know their whole [ __ ]
business is hunters and firemen and
anglers they're not anti NRA they're
definitely not anti Second Amendment
like [ __ ] relax so even after they
put out that statement
the NRA doubled down and released
another statement you know you made a
big mistake and now you're paying for it
I really think we have a real problem
and especially there's a real problem in
that regard because they need to
understand everybody they are saying we
should all anybody that supports any
outdoor activities has to understand
that the conflict if you have any
internal conflict against each other
like but the thing about hunters and
fishermen all these people what their
real opposition is is animal rights
activists and radical at Animal
Liberation Organization type people
that's the real enemy the enemy isn't
Yeti coolers who makes their business
selling [ __ ] to hunters and fishermen
and anglers like these people are crazy
so this conflict just shows to me like
people are just looking for a fight
right like right no walk it takes to get
all that [ __ ] explosive [ __ ] and put
it at a core this [ __ ] just happened I
need to get some lights boom and they're
blowing up these [ __ ] $300 $500
coolers good crazy buy and buy him up
yeah but now these this also is really
fascinating yeah I'll send this to you
Jamie because I sent it to unbelievable
my friend Ben O'Brien who's freaking out
about this cuz Ben is he's he's an
executive at Yeti my buddy Ben and you
know I sent him this thing where all
these other cool
all these other cooler companies are
freaking out and jumping in and saying
we're all sick it's on Deadspin here
Jamie I'll send it to you right now
these people kill me all these all right
I mean I don't know if they're all right
so I even alright a lot of people who
say you know liberals are snowflakes and
you cry about everything that's like
dude you guys are literally have built
careers off being victims I mean what is
happening here I mean I know that this
is not exactly the same thing but it
kind of is ridiculous now you think what
protests you throw your cared coffee
maker out there well that's John
Hattie's
truth and these goddamn livers were
trying to silence the truth and I'm not
having it from Keurig you want a boycott
shot like the Laura Ingram thing was
fascinating here it is bison coolers
look at these people only tap like if
you have a Second Amendment support us
we love guns and join the herd it says
look at that join the herd
how about join the herd what join the
herd flock you mean yeah sheep you [ __ ]
you're trying to get people to be sheep
like join the herd what do you why would
you say herd our people cattle you write
praise II [ __ ] is akin to an audience
there's a great great quote in that
scroll down a little bit Jamie scroll
down a little bit here it is scroll down
go down so I could read that bottom text
says so here we find ourselves in the
midst of a dumb as rocks arm race
between essentially indistinguishable
cooler bland brands all trying to
declare their undying devotion to guns
more fervently than their rivals the
whole [ __ ] is exactly as stupid as it
seems and amid the fog of marketing
[ __ ] and bad faith NRA posturing
there's one truth that none of this can
none of this mess can obscure 479
ninety-nine is too much to pay for a
cooler thank you solid [ __ ] coolers
they're very they're worth it if you can
keep a very for what you're using if you
go hunting or camping you can keep
racing that nervous fine [ __ ] dairy
important yeah I mean it does organs
very sane ly good coolers but who wrote
that article give that guy's hilarious
man the Deadspin author Patrick Redford
promise you Patrick
dumb as
Ochs quote so stupid they're blowing up
cause what our discourse has become yeah
it's like mass hallucinations on both
sides of the political aisle you're
either a Russian bot or troll or your
everything's fake news and it's all you
know kyun online battle or your lip tart
or snowflake it's